Nous allons reprendre ce thème de la crainte de l'homme que nous avons commencé avec le pasteur Stéphane la semaine dernière.
Nous avons vu la semaine dernière avec lui, nous avons commencé par voir ce qu'était la crainte de l'homme.
Et pour ceux qui n'étaient pas présents, je vous invite à écouter l'enregistrement qui a été fait pour rattraper ce cours.
Mais très rapidement, voici les points qui ont été abordés par Stéphane la semaine dernière.
Nous avons d'abord vu ce que signifie craindre l'homme.
Ensuite, nous avons vu comment cette crainte ou comment cette lutte contre cette crainte imprègne nos vies et toute notre culture et toute l'humanité.
Nous avons vu qui craint les hommes, aussi bien les plus faibles en apparence que les plus puissants en apparence.
Nous avons vu pourquoi nous craignons les hommes.
D'où vient cette crainte ?
Nous avons enfin vu comment l'écriture caractérise et parle de la crainte des hommes.
Et finalement, comment le fait que nous craignons les hommes, le fait que nous craignons les hommes vient du fait que nous ne craignons pas Dieu ou du moins pas assez Dieu.
Et donc, après avoir bien défini la semaine dernière ce qu'est la peur, la crainte de l'homme, nous allons ce soir définir ce qu'est la crainte de Dieu.
Comment Stéphane l'a introduit à la fin de la leçon de la semaine dernière ?
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie exactement ? De craindre Dieu.
Après tout, je pense que pour beaucoup de chrétiens, c'est peut-être l'un des commandements de la parole qui est les plus inattendus, quelque part.
craignez Dieu.
Craindre celui dont on sait qu'il nous aime.
Craindre celui qui est parfaitement bon.
Pourquoi trouvons-nous dans la parole un tel commandement pour les enfants de Dieu, pour le chrétien ?
Et donc, nous allons commencer un peu de la même manière que la semaine dernière, à examiner les Écritures pour définir ce qu'est la crainte de Dieu bibliquement.
Ensuite, nous allons voir pourquoi nous devons craindre Dieu.
Et ensuite, pourquoi nous ne le faisons pas.
Ensuite, à quoi ressemble cette crainte ?
Et enfin, nous aborderons rapidement, puisque ce sera l'objet d'une prochaine leçon, comment apprendre à marcher dans cette crainte de Dieu.
Et donc, tout d'abord, que signifie craindre Dieu ?
Et je pense que la crainte de Dieu est très contre-intuitive pour beaucoup de chrétiens, comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure.
Nous comprenons pourquoi certaines personnes devraient craindre Dieu.
Ses ennemis, par exemple.
C'est assez évident.
Quand on lit des versets comme Hébreu 10, verset 31, c'est une chose terrible que de tomber entre les mains du Dieu vivant.
Mais qu'en est-il des chrétiens ?
Tout au long de la Bible, le peuple de Dieu, les propres enfants de Dieu, sont appelés, reçoivent l'ordre de le craindre.
Alors, qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Comment cela se matérialise de craindre un Dieu qui nous aime ?
Et avant d'aller plus loin, nous devons, je pense, écarter une solution un peu trop facile à ce dilemme.
Parce qu'on pourrait répondre quelque chose du genre « Dieu est amour », un Jean 4, verset 8.
« Ou l'amour parfait bannit la crainte », un Jean 4, verset 18.
Donc, on pourrait simplement redéfinir un peu le mot « crainte » dans les passages sur la crainte de Dieu par quelque chose comme « révérence ».
Un peu comme on aurait de la révérence pour un ancien combattant ou toute autre personne élevée en dignité et que l'on respecte.
Mais ce raisonnement pose quelques problèmes.
D'abord, certains passages peuvent effectivement se lire ainsi, mais beaucoup d'autres ne permettent pas cette lecture.
Par exemple, dans Romains 11, Paul avertit les païens de ne pas prendre pour acquis leur inclusion dans le peuple de Dieu.
Il dit « Ne sois donc pas orgueilleux, mais crains.
Car si Dieu n'a pas épargné les branches naturelles, c'est-à-dire les Juifs qui n'ont pas cru,
il ne t'épargnera pas non plus. »
Et donc, n'est-ce pas, il s'agit ici bien plus que de simples révérences.
Il s'agit d'une crainte à avoir.
Et deuxièmement, je crains que si nous allons trop vite pour résoudre ce problème de la crainte de Dieu,
nous passions à côté de beaucoup de vérités, d'attributs de Dieu qui sont très importants.
Nous pouvons passer à côté de la terreur que Dieu inspire.
Et donc, de sa puissance qui en est à l'origine.
Nous pouvons passer à côté de la colère de Dieu et donc de sa justice et aussi de sa miséricorde pour nous chrétiens.
De la sainteté de Dieu qui inspire la crainte et donc de sa majesté.
Nous pouvons passer à côté de tout cela.
Dieu doit être craint.
Et il y a une bonne raison pour laquelle la Bible utilise le mot crainte plutôt que seulement révérence ou admiration.
Parfois, c'est vrai que ces mots sont synonymes, mais souvent, dans certains passages de l'Écriture, ils ne le sont pas.
Alors, que signifie craindre Dieu ?
Pour commencer, l'Écriture ne voit pas de contradiction et au contraire maintient uni le fait de craindre Dieu et d'aimer Dieu,
ou la crainte de Dieu et l'amour de Dieu.
Prenons par exemple Philippiens 2, versets 12 à 13.
Ce que vous voyez, ce qui se passe ici dans ce verset.
Dieu agit en nous.
C'est un miracle.
Il nous transforme.
Il change nos désirs.
Il nous rend saints.
Il nous transforme progressivement à l'image de son Fils.
Et pourtant, selon ce verset, cela ne semble contredire en rien la crainte et le tremblement.
Il y a une crainte sainte qui doit naître en moi lorsque je réalise que le Dieu Tout-Puissant a choisi ma vie comme une toile pour y révéler toute sa gloire.
Je tremble en comprenant que c'est lui et ce n'est pas moi qui tiens les rênes de ma vie.
Il s'agit de sa volonté, de son dessein, de son bon plaisir et pas du mien, même si tout cela est pour mon bien.
Donc voilà le premier concept pour nous aider à comprendre la crainte de Dieu.
Nous le craignons parce que c'est lui qui agit en nous et que nous ne sommes plus aux commandes de notre vie.
Le deuxième concept nous vient de Néhémie, chapitre 1, verset 11, qui dit
« Seigneur, prête l'oreille à la prière de ton serviteur et à la prière de ceux de tes serviteurs qui prennent plaisir à craindre ton nom. »
Et on retrouve cela ailleurs dans l'Écriture.
Craindre Dieu est une source de joie pour le croyant.
Ainsi, non seulement la crainte de Dieu ne contredit pas le fait que Dieu soit pour nous, que Dieu nous aime, comme on l'a vu,
mais ses enfants prennent plaisir au fait de le craindre.
La crainte de Dieu ne s'oppose pas à notre joie.
Et permettez-moi de mentionner trois autres passages qui nous aident à comprendre la crainte de Dieu avant d'en tirer une conclusion,
pour tenter de la définir au mieux.
Proverbe 28, verset 14.
Heureux l'homme qui est continuellement dans la crainte, mais celui qui endurcit son cœur tombera dans le malheur.
Il faut savoir que très souvent dans la poésie biblique, une ligne aide à interpréter la suivante,
soit par répétition, deux, trois fois, voire plus, ou par contraste.
Et ici, craindre l'éternel est mis en contraste avec le fait d'endurcir son cœur,
ce qui nous montre que la crainte inclut une composante de soumission à Dieu.
Psaume 31, verset 20.
Ici, on voit que craindre Dieu, ça équivaut à se réfugier en lui.
Et un troisième passage, psaume 147, verset 11.
« L'éternel prend plaisir en ceux qui le craignent, en ceux qui espèrent en sa bienveillance. »
Et donc, de manière semblable à l'association dans le verset juste avant qu'on a cité,
on voit ici que craindre Dieu, ce n'est pas seulement faire de lui notre refuge,
mais aussi notre espérance.
Ceux qui espèrent en sa bienveillance.
Il y a dans un des livres de John Piper, « Les plaisirs de Dieu », qui existe en français,
vous pouvez le trouver si vous voulez,
une image qui nous aide à bien comprendre tout ce qu'on a vu jusqu'ici.
Dans ce livre, en tout cas dans cet extrait,
il souligne combien il peut sembler étrange, c'est vrai,
de craindre et d'espérer en Dieu en même temps.
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas plus naturel de craindre une personne pour des raisons légitimes
et d'espérer en une autre personne pour des raisons aussi légitimes ?
Comment ces deux aspects, la crainte et l'espérance,
peuvent-ils être réunis en une seule personne, en Dieu ?
Et pour nous aider à comprendre cela,
John Piper décrit un alpiniste qui serait pris dans une tempête
et qui chercherait frénétiquement un abri
contre cette tempête mortelle qui se rapproche de lui.
Son pouce accélère, l'adrénaline monte, il est terrifié par cette tempête.
Puis il trouve un trou, une grotte dans la falaise
et il réalise rapidement qu'il va être enfin en sécurité.
C'est la même tempête, il a la même peur,
mais maintenant, il a trouvé l'espérance et le refuge.
Et donc voici, je cite, l'explication de Piper.
Nous devrions laisser l'expérience de l'espérance
pénétrer et transformer l'expérience de la peur.
En d'autres termes, la crainte que nous devons avoir envers Dieu
est ce qui reste de la peur
lorsqu'on a une espérance certaine au milieu de celle-ci.
La crainte de Dieu, c'est ce qui reste de la tempête
quand on a un endroit sûr d'où la contempler en son centre.
Et depuis ce refuge, on peut dire, c'est incroyable, c'est terrifiant,
c'est une puissance incroyable qui peut me détruire.
Quelle émotion d'être ici au cœur de cette puissance redoutable de Dieu
et pourtant protégée par Dieu lui-même.
Ainsi, nous comprenons comment l'on peut ressentir
à la fois de l'espérance et de la crainte.
L'espérance transforme la crainte en émerveillement tremblant et paisible.
Et la crainte ôte tout ce qu'il y a de banal dans l'espérance,
la rendant sérieuse et profonde.
Les terreurs de Dieu rendent les plaisirs de son peuple intenses.
Fin de la citation.
Donc essayons de synthétiser ce que nous venons de dire.
« La crainte de Dieu découle de la puissance et de la colère de Dieu. »
Puissance et colère que l'on voit le plus clairement lorsque Dieu juge.
Même si nous savons qu'en Christ, ce jugement est tombé sur lui à notre place.
La crainte de Dieu implique une soumission humble
et connaissant à la fois la terreur et l'amour de Dieu,
la crainte de Dieu place son espérance en lui, fait de lui son refuge.
Ainsi, le chrétien prend plaisir à craindre Dieu.
Voici une courte définition qui tente de résumer tout cela.
« La crainte de Dieu est une soumission révérencieuse
qui conduit à une confiance obéissante et à l'adoration. »
Mais même cette définition ne rend pas pleinement compte
du sentiment que produit la crainte de Dieu.
Après tout, c'est un sujet, la crainte de Dieu,
une vérité qui se décrit mieux qu'elle ne se définit.
Et vous pouvez lire les derniers chapitres de Job ou d'Apocalypse,
« Prendre du recul et vous émerveiller
que ce Dieu se nomme lui-même votre Père. »
Face à un tel Dieu, il n'est pas surprenant
qu'il soit ordonné à toute la création,
à tous les hommes de le craindre,
comme on peut le lire au psaume 33, verset 8,
« Que toute la terre craigne l'éternel,
que tous les habitants du monde tremblent devant lui. »
Avant de poursuivre, est-ce que vous avez des questions sur ce point ?
Donc, le titre en anglais, pour ceux qui voudraient le lire en anglais,
c'est « The pleasures of God »
et le titre en français, c'est « Les plaisirs de Dieu ».
J'ai vérifié juste avant.
Normalement, il se trouve encore sur Internet.
Oui, de la crainte de Dieu.
La crainte de Dieu est une soumission révérencieuse
qui conduit à une confiance obéissante et à l'adoration.
Voilà donc ce que signifie craindre Dieu.
Et c'est quelque chose que nous devrions tous vivre.
Mais cela soulève une autre question importante
qui est notre deuxième point.
Pourquoi devons-nous craindre Dieu ?
Et comme vous le verrez, la réponse se structure en trois grands sous-points,
trois grandes catégories.
Mais avant d'aborder ce deuxième point,
je pars du principe que vous voulez craindre Dieu.
Sinon, vous ne seriez probablement pas dans cette salle.
Mais faites un exercice durant les prochaines minutes.
Essayez de ne pas prendre pour acquis que vous êtes déjà convaincu
de craindre Dieu
ou que vous devez le craindre
ou que vous voulez le craindre.
Mais cherchez plutôt s'il y a des raisons,
peut-être nouvelles pour vous,
qui vous aideront à le craindre au mieux
et à le craindre davantage.
Pourquoi devons-nous craindre Dieu ?
La première raison, c'est qu'en tant que porteur
de l'image du seul vrai Dieu,
nous avons été créés par lui pour le craindre.
Genèse 1, verset 26 à 27 dit
« Puis Dieu dit
« Faisons l'homme à notre image,
selon notre ressemblance,
et qu'il domine sur les poissons de la mer,
sur les oiseaux du ciel,
sur le bétail, sur toute la terre,
et sur tout reptile qui rampe sur la terre.
Dieu créa l'homme à son image,
il le créa à l'image de Dieu,
il créa l'homme et la femme. »
Alors, ce passage ne parle pas explicitement
de la crainte de Dieu,
mais cette idée y est présente partout.
Est-ce que vous y voyez cette soumission révérencieuse
dont nous avons parlé ?
Nous avons été créés pour servir le seul vrai Dieu.
Pas seulement par nos actions,
mais dans notre être même.
Dieu nous a conçus
dans ce que nous sommes
et dans ce que nous faisons
pour refléter combien
il est merveilleux.
Vous avez été fait à son image.
Votre valeur en tant qu'être humain
découle de celle de Dieu lui-même.
Et voyez-vous l'aspect adoration ici.
L'adoration, ce n'est pas seulement
ce que nous faisons le dimanche matin.
L'adoration, c'est notre réponse
à la grandeur de Dieu.
Nos vies entières
en tant que porteurs de son image
devraient être cette réponse.
Dieu nous a conçus pour vivre
sans honte les uns envers les autres,
les uns devant les autres,
sans peur d'être exposés ou rejetés
pour revenir au thème de cette série.
Nous avons été créés
pour craindre Dieu
dans notre être
et dans nos actions.
C'est la première raison.
La deuxième,
c'est que Dieu est digne
de notre crainte.
Il est digne de notre obéissance.
Il est digne de notre adoration.
Psaume 89, verset 7.
Qui dans le ciel
peut se comparer à l'éternel ?
Qui est semblable à toi
parmi les fils de Dieu ?
Dieu est redoutable
dans la grande assemblée des saints,
terrible pour tous ceux
qui l'entourent.
Dieu est plus redoutable
que tous ceux qui l'entourent
et pour cela,
simplement pour cela,
Dieu est digne
de notre crainte.
Psaume 90, verset 11.
Qui prend garde
à la force de ta colère
et à ton courroux
selon la crainte
qui t'est due ?
Nous craignons Dieu
parce qu'il est redoutable.
Nous le craignons particulièrement
parce qu'il est redoutable
dans sa colère
et dans son courroux.
Moïse,
qui a écrit ce verset
du psaume 90,
a certainement vu
la colère de Dieu
dirigée contre les Égyptiens,
dirigée contre le peuple
rebelle d'Israël aussi,
malheureusement.
Il n'a jamais vu cette colère
s'abattre sur lui personnellement,
même s'il a expérimenté
la discipline paternelle de Dieu,
mais voir de près
la colère divine
a bouleversé sa vie.
Et sans aucun doute,
Moïse comprenait
que sans la miséricorde de Dieu,
il méritait lui aussi
d'être l'objet
de cette colère.
Et cela peut
soulever
une autre question
pour nous,
chrétiens.
Si j'ai été sauvé
de la colère de Dieu,
pourquoi devrais-je
encore
craindre
cette colère ?
Et l'Épître aux Hébreux
aborde cela
plusieurs reprises.
Un bon exemple
se trouve à la fin
du chapitre 12.
C'est pourquoi
recevant un royaume
inébranlable,
soyons reconnaissants
et rendons à Dieu
un culte
qui lui soit agréable
avec piété
et avec
crainte
car
notre Dieu
est un feu dévorant.
Dernier chapitre
d'une lettre
du Nouveau Testament
adressée
aux chrétiens
d'une église.
Nous sommes reconnaissants
pour la grâce de Dieu
qui a fait de nous
des fils et des filles
du roi
au lieu de nous juger
comme les rebelles
que nous étions.
Mais cela ne doit pas
détourner
la juste orientation
de nos vies,
de nos affections
autour de celui
qui est le juge
de toute la terre.
Il est un feu dévorant.
De toute éternité,
Dieu n'a pas changé.
Il est et reste
un feu dévorant.
Il est infiniment
digne
de notre crainte
qui lui est due
comme nous l'avons lu.
Et cela nous pousse
à l'adorer
tout en nous protégeant
de l'égarement.
Encore une fois,
Dieu est digne
de notre crainte
même lorsqu'il nous assure
de sa miséricorde.
Ces deux choses
ne sont pas contradictoires.
Et cela nous amène
à la troisième réponse,
au troisième sous-point.
Nous craignons Dieu
parce que c'est
pour notre bien.
Trois versets,
court.
Psaume 111, verset 10.
La crainte de l'éternel
est le commencement
de la sagesse
et de la connaissance.
Psaume 115, verset 11.
Dieu est un secours
et un bouclier
pour ceux qui le craignent.
Psaume 115, verset 13.
Il bénira
ceux qui craignent
l'éternel.
Craindre Dieu
est bon pour nous.
C'est une source
de bénédiction
pour nos vies.
Dieu est un secours
et un bouclier personnel
pour ceux qui le craignent.
Avant de continuer,
est-ce que vous avez
des questions sur ce point ?
Pourquoi devons-nous
craindre Dieu ?
Très bien,
continuons.
Donc, nous avons,
je pense que nous l'avons vu,
toutes les raisons
de craindre Dieu.
Et pourtant,
souvent,
ou parfois,
nous ne craignons pas
Dieu
ou pas suffisamment
Dieu.
Et pourquoi cela arrive ?
C'était certainement
vrai avant notre conversion
et malheureusement,
ça arrive encore
après notre conversion.
En résumé,
nous ne craignons pas Dieu
à cause de notre choix
en tant que race humaine
de péché.
et la non-crainte de Dieu
est une conséquence
de notre péché
et plus précisément
de notre idolâtrie.
Comme Paul le dit
dans Romains,
chapitre 1,
verset 23,
nous avons changé
la gloire du Dieu incorruptible
en images,
représentant l'homme
corruptible,
les oiseaux,
des quadrupèdes
et des reptiles.
Nous avons effectué
la transaction
la plus désastreuse
possible pour nous
en choisissant
de rejeter l'adoration
et la crainte de Dieu
pour vénérer
et craindre
sa création
à la place.
Désormais,
nos vies ne sont plus
centrées sur lui
mais sur des choses
qu'il a créées.
Et prenons un instant
pour observer
la triste ironie
de cette situation.
Qui devrait craindre
le plus
un Dieu saint,
juste
et terrifiant ?
Eh bien,
des pécheurs,
des pécheurs comme nous.
Et pourquoi ne craignons-nous
pas Dieu ?
Eh bien,
parce que
nous sommes pécheurs.
Voyez à quel point
le péché est destructeur,
à quel point
il obstrue
et piège
notre intelligence.
Alors,
que s'est-il passé
lorsque nous avons fait
cette terrible transaction
en Adam ?
Regardons Genèse 3.
Immédiatement
après avoir péché,
Adam et Ève
se sont cachés.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien,
parce qu'ils avaient
honte.
Ils avaient honte
l'un de l'autre,
l'un devant l'autre
et devant Dieu.
Et à la fin
du récit
de la création
en Genèse 2,
il est dit
qu'Adam et sa femme
étaient tous deux nus
et ils n'en avaient
point honte.
Ils n'avaient
à ce moment-là,
avant la chute,
rien à cacher
devant Dieu
et l'un devant l'autre.
Mais désormais,
eux
et nous
à leur suite
qui avons hérité
du même péché
qu'Adam et Ève,
nous avons
beaucoup à cacher.
Et c'est pourquoi
nous avons peur
d'être exposés
au regard des autres.
Et non seulement cela,
mais Adam et Ève
et tous les êtres humains
à leur suite
sont désormais
aliénés l'un de l'autre.
C'est-à-dire que
Adam blâme sa femme
pour son propre péché.
Et une partie
de la malédiction de Dieu
sur eux
à cause de leur péché
se manifeste
par cette division
au sein de leur mariage.
il y a désormais
une crainte,
un blâme,
un rejet mutuel
dans le couple
et entre tous les hommes.
Et ce rejet
est si profond
qu'il mènera
à une peur légitime
de subir des dommages physiques.
Au lieu de préserver,
de promouvoir la vie,
les porteurs
de l'image de Dieu
que nous sommes
vont se retourner
les uns contre les autres
comme nous le voyons
malheureusement
dans le premier meurtre
de Cain
qui tue son frère Abel.
Nous devons voir la chute
comme l'événement
cataclysmique
qu'elle est
dans les Écritures.
La chute
change tout.
Les créatures
sont désormais
nues et exposées.
Elles sont vivantes,
certes,
mais spirituellement mortes.
Elles sont humaines,
toujours,
mais un aspect essentiel
de ce que signifie
être humain
a été brisé
en chacun de nous.
Notre crainte
de l'homme
est la conséquence directe
de notre rejet de Dieu
en tant que notre Dieu
avec tout ce que cela implique.
Et c'est un point crucial
à ne pas manquer.
Très souvent,
nous traitons
les symptômes
de la crainte de l'homme
comme s'ils étaient
le véritable problème,
comme si le vrai souci
c'était cette personne
que je crains,
dont j'ai peur
ou ces besoins
non satisfaits
dans ma vie
qui nourrissent
mon insécurité,
mon angoisse,
mes frustrations.
Mais nous ne pourrons
jamais vraiment saisir
quel est le problème
tant que nous n'aurons
pas compris
qu'à sa racine
se trouve notre péché.
Nous avons choisi
de rejeter
la crainte de Dieu.
Ce qui signifie
que nous avons hérité
cette crainte
de l'homme,
de notre père Adam.
C'est inscrit en nous,
dans notre chair.
Le problème est en nous
et non pas autour de nous
dans les circonstances
de notre vie.
Et pourtant,
aussi tragique
soit le tableau
que je viens de peindre,
il y a une solution
à ce problème.
Le problème est en nous
mais la solution
à ce problème
est en dehors de nous,
en la personne
de notre sauveur
Jésus-Christ.
Jésus a craint
Dieu son père
parfaitement
toute sa vie.
Il a accompli
pour nous
à notre place
ce pour quoi
nous avions été créés.
Craindre,
adorer,
servir,
aimer Dieu.
Et de même
qu'en Adam
nous avons tous
péché en Christ.
Pour ceux
qui se repentent
et croient,
qui placent leur foi
en lui,
nous sommes tous
rendus justes.
Cela signifie
que même si nous étions
nus comme pécheurs
devant Dieu,
en Adam,
en Christ,
nous sommes
revêtus
de sa justice.
Quelqu'un un jour
a dit
quand nous essayons
de nous couvrir
et de nous protéger
de la crainte
des autres
ou plutôt
de nous couvrir
et nous protéger
en craignant
les autres,
c'est comme si nous
tentions de nous cacher
derrière quelques graviers
alors que pendant ce temps,
une montagne
entière de protection
nous est enferte
en Jésus-Christ.
Frères et sœurs,
méditez sur la justice
et la rédemption
qui vous est offerte
en Jésus-Christ.
Vous devriez à juste titre
craindre Dieu
à cause de la manière
dont vous l'avez rejeté
et déshonoré autrefois
et cela arrive encore
malheureusement
à cause du reste
de péché
qu'il y a en nous
mais en Christ.
Vous pouvez maintenant
craindre Dieu
comme celui
qui vous aime
parfaitement
et définitivement.
Quelle merveilleuse nouvelle
que celle de l'Évangile,
quel réconfort
pour nos âmes
d'être assurés
de cela.
Donc jusqu'ici,
nous avons défini
la crainte de Dieu,
nous avons examiné
pourquoi nous devrions
craindre Dieu,
pourquoi nous ne craignons
pas Dieu
et maintenant,
alors que nous approchons
à la fin de cette leçon,
voyons à quoi cela
ressemble concrètement
de craindre Dieu.
À quoi ressemble
la crainte de Dieu ?
Nous trouvons dans la Bible
des descriptions
de la crainte de Dieu
en action
et je ne vais pas
toutes les lire maintenant
mais voici un aperçu rapide.
À quoi cela ressemble-t-il
de craindre le Seigneur
de manière pratique
dans notre vie chrétienne ?
Cela ressemble
à louer Dieu,
écouter la vérité
qui vient de lui,
être silencieux
et enseignable
face à sa parole,
avoir un cœur intègre
qui n'est pas partagé,
suivre ses commandements,
espérer en sa parole,
comprendre ses lois,
trembler devant sa loi,
marcher dans ses voies,
être humble,
haïr le mal
et marcher dans l'intégrité.
Et cette liste
n'est probablement pas exhaustive.
La crainte du Dieu,
ce n'est pas un slogan,
frères et sœurs,
elle se manifeste concrètement
dans la vie des croyants.
Mais bien sûr,
la Bible ne donne pas seulement
des descriptions
de la crainte de Dieu,
elle nous donne aussi
de bons exemples
de personnes
qui ont craint Dieu
plus que les hommes.
Est-ce que vous pouvez penser
à des personnes dans la Bible
qui ont craint Dieu
plus que les hommes ?
Je vous laisse quelques minutes
pour citer des noms.
Enoch.
Est-il dans ma liste ?
Pierre.
Pierre, oui.
Paul, exactement.
Daniel, Chedra,
Chedra,
Chedra.
Jérémie, oui.
Bon, ma liste n'est pas exhaustive.
Non, mais...
Vous en avez dit déjà plusieurs.
Donc, je vais vous en donner d'autres
avec un rappel
de comment ça s'est concrétisé
pour eux,
de craindre Dieu
plus que l'homme.
Noé.
Même si le texte
ne rapporte pas directement
ce que les gens
pouvaient dire à Noé,
on peut facilement imaginer
à quel point il a dû craindre
Dieu plus que les hommes
pendant qu'il construisait
un immense bateau
dans son jardin,
un endroit où il n'avait
jamais plus,
et cela pendant des décennies.
Daniel,
effectivement,
avec ses amis
Chedra, Meshach et Abednego,
le livre de Daniel
regorge d'exemples
où ils ont
ce groupe
d'amis,
de croyants.
On craint Dieu
plus que les hommes.
Leur refus de manger
l'aimé du roi.
Leur refus de se prosterner
devant l'idole.
Peut-être l'élément
le plus important
de ce livre.
La décision de Daniel
de continuer à prier
malgré l'interdiction royale.
son courage
pour interpréter
les rêves,
connaissant les risques
que cela avait pour lui.
Et à chaque fois,
ils ont craint Dieu
plus que les hommes.
Esther,
face au complot
sournois d'Aman
pour exterminer
le peuple de Dieu,
Esther décide
d'approcher
le roi Xerces
en sachant que cela
pouvait lui coûter
la vie,
puisqu'elle l'a fait
d'une manière
qui normalement
coûtait la vie
de la personne
qui osait s'approcher
du roi de cette manière.
Mais elle l'a quand même fait,
par crainte de Dieu
et par amour
pour son peuple.
Ruth,
qui en allant glaner
dans les champs,
a pris un risque réel
d'agression physique
ou même sexuelle.
Et elle a agi pourtant
dans la foi
et la crainte
du Seigneur.
Rahab,
qui a caché
les espions israélites,
qui a refusé
de se soumettre
à la peur
généralisée
qui régnait
dans Jéricho,
elle n'a pas craint
les autorités
de la ville
et leurs menaces,
mais elle a craint
le Dieu d'Israël
plus que eux.
Marie,
la mère de Jésus,
elle loue le Seigneur,
célèbre sa bonté
et parle de sa crainte
du Seigneur
et de sa joie
de porter
dans son sein
le Fils de Dieu,
malgré la crainte
qu'elle pouvait avoir
en tant que femme
et mère.
L'apôtre Paul,
il suit fidèlement
le Seigneur
de sa conversion
jusqu'à son martyr
sous Néron,
démontrant
ce que signifie
craindre Dieu
alors qu'il annonce
l'Évangile aux nations
et bien sûr
toutes les persécutions
qu'il a subies
sur le chemin.
Les femmes
qui ont couru
au tombeau,
malgré la peur
et les événements
tragiques
auxquels elles ont assisté,
elles vont au tombeau
animées par la foi
et une sainte crainte.
Pierre,
effectivement,
plus tard dans sa vie,
Dieu l'a transformé,
il était autrefois
plein de craintes
des hommes,
comme vous le savez,
et Dieu l'a transformé
en un homme obéissant
au point de briser
ses anciens repères
pour entrer
dans la maison
de Corneille.
Celui qui avait peur
est devenu celui
qui exhorte les croyants
de tous les temps
à ne pas craindre
les hommes
mais à faire confiance
à Dieu,
digne de crainte
et fidèle
en toutes choses.
Jésus,
évidemment,
le parfait exemple
de celui
qui a craint Dieu
en tout temps,
marchant dans l'obéissance
jusqu'à la mort
de la croix.
Vous pouvez lire aussi
le chapitre 11
de l'Épître aux Hébreux
où l'auteur présente
une longue liste
de héros de la foi
tous marqués
par leur crainte de Dieu
manifestée
par leur foi
en lui.
Mais la Bible
n'est pas le seul témoignage,
il y a aussi
l'histoire de l'Église
qui est remplie
d'hommes et de femmes
qui ont fidèlement
suivi Dieu
pour faire avancer
son royaume.
Polycarpe,
j'en cite uniquement trois
mais il y en a évidemment
beaucoup plus,
Polycarpe et d'autres
martyrs de l'Église primitive
qui ont courageusement
affronté la mort
en proclamant la bonté
et la douceur du Christ
face à ceux
qui allaient les tuer.
Luther,
lorsqu'il s'est courageusement
tenu devant les autorités
de son temps,
les autorités ecclésiastiques,
pour proclamer
la grande vérité
de la justification
par le moyen
de la foi seule.
Et enfin,
Jim Elliot,
plus récemment
dans notre histoire,
qui est allé courageusement
dans les jungles
d'Amérique du Sud
et a donné sa vie
pour proclamer l'Évangile
à des tribus
éloignées
de toute civilisation.
Des frères et sœurs
dans le monde entier
encore aujourd'hui
qui sont tués
en raison de leur foi.
Alors,
voici un grand nombre
de très bons exemples.
Mais le dernier point
qui nous intéressera ce soir,
comment faisons-nous cela ?
Comment apprendre
à grandir
dans la crainte de Dieu ?
Ça sera un point rapide
parce que comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure,
ça sera l'objet
d'une future leçon.
Nous allons quand même
présenter quelques points
ce soir.
Seule une crainte
plus grande
peut chasser
une autre crainte
plus petite.
Nous adorons
ce que nous craignons
le plus.
Et notre préoccupation,
c'est un point important,
notre préoccupation principale
ne devrait pas être
de trouver des solutions
pour ne plus avoir peur
des hommes,
mais plutôt
de rechercher
à avoir une crainte
plus profonde
du Seigneur.
cette perspective
est cruciale.
Si vous quittez
ce cours
sur la crainte
de l'homme
en vous sentant
moins contrôlé
par ce que les autres
pensent,
mais sans avoir
une plus grande
crainte de Dieu,
alors vous serez
passé à côté
du but
de ce cours,
de ce thème.
Car notre objectif
n'est pas simplement
d'échapper
à la peur des hommes,
mais c'est d'abord
d'apprendre
à mieux connaître
et à mieux craindre
notre Dieu.
Alors comment grandir
dans cette crainte
du Seigneur ?
Nous développerons plus tard,
mais voici un bref résumé
de ce que vous pouvez faire
pour apprendre
à grandir
dans cette crainte.
Apprenez qui est Dieu
selon les enseignements
de la Bible
et n'évitez pas
les passages
qui parlent
de sa justice,
de sa colère,
de sa puissance,
de sa haine du péché
et du pécheur.
Parfois,
en tant que chrétien,
nous nous concentrons
principalement sur notre essai
de réconcilier
ces passages
sur ces thèmes-là
avec l'amour de Dieu.
Et c'est une bonne chose
car c'est réconciliable
comme on l'a vu
au début du cours.
Mais si c'est tout
ce que nous faisons,
nous perdons un atout
essentiel
de l'Écriture
qui nous aide
à croître
dans la crainte
du Seigneur.
Pour citer
une nouvelle fois
Hébreu 12,
notre feu,
notre Dieu
est un feu dévorant.
Quelques rappels
mais le Dieu,
notre Dieu,
dans sa parole
se révèle à nous
de cette manière.
Il est saint.
Il est majestueux.
Il est souverain.
Il est omnipotent,
c'est-à-dire tout-puissant.
Il est omniscient,
c'est-à-dire qu'il sait
toute chose.
Il est omniprésent,
c'est-à-dire qu'il est présent
partout,
en tout temps.
Miséricordieux,
bon,
fidèle,
aimant,
jaloux,
juste
et rempli de colère
contre le péché.
Et deux livres
en dehors de la Bible
qui constituent
d'excellents points
de départ
pour apprendre
à mieux connaître
et comprendre Dieu.
Connaître Dieu
de J.A. Packer
que je vous recommande
très vivement
de lire
avant de quitter
cette terre
comme le dit souvent David
et Les plaisirs de Dieu
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure
de John Piper.
Ces deux livres
sont une très bonne base
en plus de la Bible
évidemment
pour croître
dans votre connaissance
de Dieu
et donc dans votre crainte
de Dieu.
Une deuxième chose
que vous pouvez faire
pour grandir
dans cette crainte,
c'est observer
la bonté de Dieu
dans la Bible
et dans votre vie.
Comme nous l'avons vu
au début
de cette leçon,
la crainte de Dieu
pour le chrétien
ce n'est pas seulement
la crainte
de la tempête
mais la crainte
en sachant
qu'on est en sécurité.
Plus vous êtes submergé
à la fois
par la terreur de Dieu
et par sa bonté,
plus vous allez le craindre
convenablement.
Une troisième chose
que vous pouvez faire,
c'est ne pas fuir
votre propre péché.
Au lieu de le minimiser,
de vous mettre
sur la défensive,
de décider de simplement
oublier,
de passer à autre chose,
vous devez honnêtement
confesser votre péché
devant Dieu.
Réfléchissez attentivement
à la racine
de votre péché
dans votre cœur
puis courez à la croix
pour recevoir
le pardon de Dieu
et en comprenant mieux
votre péché,
vous comprendrez mieux
l'amour de Dieu
pour vous,
sa miséricorde,
son pardon
et vous grandirez
dans une sainte crainte
du Seigneur.
Et un dernier point,
repentez-vous,
repentons-nous
de notre orgueil ?
Je ne saurais que
trop insister là-dessus.
Notre orgueil est bien
plus profond
que ce que nous
pouvons imaginer.
Il est enraciné
dans la trame même
de ce que nous sommes
en tant que rebelles
contre Dieu.
L'orgueil déforme
totalement la réalité
en tentant de faire
de nous quelque chose
d'important
et de Dieu
quelque chose
de peu important.
Est-ce que vous auriez
des questions
avant la conclusion ?
Oui.
On vit dans une société
où il y a des personnes
qui sont religieuses
et qui portent
un témoignage
religieux selon les œuvres
en fait,
les religions d'œuvres
et leur témoignage
justement,
c'est
je crains Dieu
parce que je respecte
ses commandements
et j'aimerais
qu'on mette en trace
en fait,
la vraie crainte
de Dieu
avec l'origine,
la démarche
et la finalité
de cette fausse crainte
de Dieu
qu'on retrouve
dans les religions d'œuvres.
Je pense que le point
qui répond à ça,
c'est la définition
justement avec cette image
qu'a donnée John Piper
qui n'a pas seulement
l'aspect crainte de Dieu,
crainte de ses commandements,
crainte de la conséquence
de ne pas oublier
à ses commandements,
mais que la vraie crainte
de Dieu biblique,
c'est ça
plus l'assurance
qui vient de l'Évangile
faire face à Dieu
tel qu'il est.
En fait,
ce n'est pas que
ce que ces personnes-là
pensent
ou vivent
est faux,
mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Il manque quelque chose.
Il leur manque
cette partie-là
de confiance,
de contempler
cette tempête
terrifiante
en se sentant
malgré tout
en sécurité.
C'est ça
la sainte crainte de Dieu.
S'il n'y a pas
ces deux composantes,
ce n'est pas
la crainte biblique de Dieu,
du chrétien en tout cas.
C'est soit
la crainte du pécheur
qui est normale,
soit
pas de crainte.
S'il n'y a que
l'aspect confiance
en sécurité,
comme on l'a dit
un peu plus tôt,
on aura du mal
à avoir une adoration
avec cette révérence
et cette juste crainte.
Pour conclure
cette leçon,
nous pouvons dire
que craindre Dieu,
c'est d'abord
prendre conscience
qu'il en est
infiniment digne
de par son être,
de par ses œuvres
et qu'il nous ordonne
dans sa parole
de le craindre.
C'est un commandement.
Nous le craignons
en nous soumettant
à lui avec révérence,
d'une manière
qui conduit
à l'obéissance
et à l'adoration.
Craindre Dieu,
c'est lui obéir
avec joie
et avec bonheur.
Craindre Dieu,
c'est comme nous l'avons vu
le commencement
de la sagesse.
Et n'oubliez pas
que Dieu seul
peut porter le poids
de vos désirs
les plus profonds.
Lui seul
est capable
de recevoir
l'adoration
pour laquelle
il vous a créé.
Alors,
frères et sœurs,
craignons notre Dieu
pour notre bien
et pour notre joie.
Amen.